when you come from a really great
upbringing and you're you're I guess
your parent and you're providing a roof
over your child's hell head and you're
providing them with clean water how do
you teach your child the importance of
giving back and how do you teach them
kind of like the importance of what
you're both doing well I think there are
a number of ways I think you it's a
topic of conversation in your house at
the dinner table I think that's one way
yeah to try to help them understand that
you know it's hard at the x-6 for
instance kids are very you know they're
you know they're kind of have the
solipsistic view of the world and but as
they start to get older and start to
realize there are people who live in
different ways and you know obviously my
kids are very lucky because my job takes
me all over the world so they've
traveled a lot so they've been they've
been able to see firsthand
oh this kids my age and this is their
experience and it's completely different
from mine and so so that's one really
helpful way but but I think it's just a
constant I mean I think it's how our
parents did it you know what I mean you
know I wasn't able to travel the way my
kids are but but but it was something
that both my parents talked to me about
and you know I think if you if you can
get them out of their own head and into
the into the understanding that you know
there are people far less fortunate than
they are then I think naturally
hopefully that hmm
that that that that way of thinking will
take over my daughter is starting to
understand a bit what I do she's like oh
mommy's on TV or she goes on a red
carpet and talks to famous people but
she doesn't quite grasp it right do your
kids understand that you're a big movie
star and you're a philanthropist and you
do good for the world I think it depends
on their ages like you know I think one
thing now is this generation with the
phones the cameras are all like
everyone's kind of on TV okay so that
it's you know daddy's on sometimes
daddy's on TV on phone and sometimes I'm
on my phone and sometimes I mean and so
I think they've been spared a little bit
but I did they start to figure it out
and obviously a lot of the movies I make
are rated R rated pg-13 I did a movie a
long time ago called spirit which is an
animated movie about a horse
which they love but that's they kind of
understand that I'm the voice of a horse
what is the movie that you do not want
them to see or you would like to prolong
them well I don't mean like look there
are a lot of move like The Departed is a
great movie I'm very proud of but you
know it's pretty violent I don't think
so how do you feel I mean it's been
eight years that water or has been going
strong how do you feel that you're
making such a difference in the world
that must be rewarding yeah I mean I
think we were excited with how well
things have gone but that just gets us
committed to redoubling our efforts
tonight there's so much more to do the
problem is so vast but we are we look
our mission is to put ourselves out of
business and and and and to be part of
this generation that ends this in our
lifetime and we feel like we can do that
and we really feel like we're we're
marching kind of in that direction and
so that just makes us want to recommit
you know